the day that guy dies I want to see like
the [ __ ] head guy he's like this
maybe that guy dies and he just has a
team
[Music]
all right this one I'm gonna tell you
this story that happened in Vietnam
you're gonna say it's the coolest [ __ ]
ever and then and then I'll tell you how
it ends and you're gonna regret saying
that so these um
basically this guy in Vietnam right he
gets uh admitted to a psychiatric ward
and within two years he becomes really
close friends with the staff he then
ends up partnering with another guy and
they start throwing these drug-fueled
sex-crazed Raves at the psychiatric in
the soundproof room of the psychiatric
ward oh [ __ ] with the staff's knowledge
yeah well maybe the staff is in on it
too yeah they are that's pretty cool
that is awesome so far everything is
cool yes yes very cool do you like house
music and in the psychiatric ward the
rump room do they bring in the The
Crazies in the party with them all of it
yeah so so they'll get like let's call
it the crazy house Club they got in like
DJ decks huge speakers lighting it's
like a straight up underground raid in
the psychiatric ward and they're
bringing [ __ ] with the straight
jackets and taking that [ __ ] off yo all
of that so they all had just like little
glow sticks at the end of their straight
jacket sleeves that they could twirl and
[ __ ] this [ __ ] should be a freaking
movie because they were doing it for a
long time and they ran a Narcotics ring
where they Supply drugs for the people
who are recovering addicts oh [ __ ] this
is getting cooler it's getting cooler
well they can sell tickets was it open
to the public or was it a private it was
some Speakeasy [ __ ] baby that's some
tight ass would you speak crazy because
that'll be nuts if you're just like hey
dude like I got this one party but it's
at a psych ward and it's operating and
you can party with people that are nuts
right so it's like when you're there
like you could be like that party was
crazy huh like literally it was [ __ ]
crazy
that's not a good idea too real bro yo
so he had he brought in MDMA ketamine
meth uh and was just it was like orgies
it was the craziest parties and it was
all in this like room that the outside
of the building couldn't hear like the
[ __ ] that was going on orgies in there
wow honestly if you're in a psych ward
though like what that's the most awesome
[ __ ] you could do you know what I mean
like that's if I wasn't crazy house I'd
be like I want to [ __ ] party with
lights and [ __ ] I mean if I if I came to
the acceptance that I too was crazy you
know what I mean otherwise like imagine
people that are like man I'm not crazy
I'm in this [ __ ] sight word all these
other people are crazy
like this right like
[Music]
hey hey you want some [ __ ] ecstasy
and then he's like huh yeah right and
you give it to him and also he turns
into a new person all sudden he does the
same thing but there's purpose
and he's like oh thank God I'm back to
normal what's up yo
I don't know if this is a lot but um so
so 2020 is the year that he started
these he wasn't caught until uh March of
this year do you think because of the
lockdown and all that stuff people just
like they weren't paying attention to it
yeah I mean that's real that's a really
under the radar thing to do no matter
what's going on in society like who's
really checking out what's going on
inside of a psych ward that's true so my
question is was he exploiting these
people or was he doing community service
to me it sounds like he was doing
something kind of thing yeah I think
he's uh honestly philanthropist yeah he
sounds like a great guy other than the
other than the fact that people are
trying to rehab from drugs and they're
getting them in the [ __ ] psych ward
which is pretty like crazy he's just
this is the pitch he's like hey look
they all think we're crazy already
anyway yeah so is this a lot of drugs uh
during that time they'd sold over 15
kilograms of drugs is that a lot uh I
don't know of what drug MDMA ketamine
and meth I mean that's a good amount for
a psych ward in one soundproof area for
two years yeah 15 kilos good amount
that's over 30 pounds
yeah how do you think this all ends
people died
when people leave they're gonna I think
I think the government is involved for
it to happen like for it to go on for
that long so I think for sure so the two
dudes that were like the um the heads of
this operation ring leaders the ring
leaders yeah uh a couple of nguins they
uh all we do is win win
they uh they were caught and sentenced
to death holy [ __ ] so no one actually
died at the party they got killed by
that
so still to this day no fatalities in
the party oh what the [ __ ] the parties
were Flawless guys the parties were safe
but the promoters died yeah I know that
sucks they got sentenced to death and
two nurses and a tech at the hospital
were sentenced to five to seven years in
prison what's the rule they broke though
yeah yeah like you're giving these
people a good time but like in your Rave
days wouldn't this be the sickest friend
like if you found out about that [ __ ]
and it was under the radar I pretend to
be crazy just get in there like sit in
front of the courthouse just wiping poop
of myself
you're crazy you're sitting there wiping
poop on yourself like dude this guy's
crazy get him in that's like the VIP
access though and they're like you
didn't have to do all that bro
for the Raves you have to like go to
this place call this pager go here meet
at the parking lot of [ __ ] bag comes
up you just jump in and [ __ ] like this
is like the thing where the gateway to
the Speakeasy is you gotta prove that
you're crazy to the court system and
then you get in and then you can party
and then you got to be cool with the
promoter later getting like assassinated
true the crazy thing damn I don't I
don't know I don't think about that how
freaking charismatic is that dude he got
admitted to that hospital as a patient
and turned this around and made friends
with everybody and started that
operation
hey Vietnamese promoters are a different
thing they're a different breed yeah
yeah they are venomous poems are good
that's a movie bro that's got to be a
film man I wonder what he went in for
that's the Vietnamese Project X in a way
yeah he had to go out like Braveheart
you know Braveheart screams Freedom
before he dies
[Laughter]
how do they do the death penalty in
Vietnam I don't know it just says that
they're yeah I mean they'll probably
he's on death row I don't know which
which one he's gonna get death by my man
that's what I was thinking what was it
called wait [ __ ] waterboarding with
[ __ ] fish sauce
damn that's looking crazy
let's see what this is he on death row
right now or he already died he's on
death row now yeah he probably don't
waste no time out there yeah because
expenses keep them alive petition dude
that's what I forget sometimes is we're
just like they're in the wrong country
bring them to America
I I forget sometimes how people do [ __ ]
in other countries like the laws and
[ __ ] and like
the same stuff we could get away with
here it's like a slap on the wrist over
there it's like you die look at that
female basketball player
for having a [ __ ] vape and some
little bit of weed hey that's the law oh
dude they don't play [ __ ] in Indonesia
they caught those kids uh smuggling some
coke
um into Indonesia they got they got
executed dude drug trafficking through
those Asian countries
they'll kill you on site man that's the
crazy thing you don't even get a [ __ ]
uh trial so they said that um back in
the day they did firing squad with seven
officers for death penalty and now it is
lethal injection
is the preferred method okay so these
two dudes we're nicer now what if he's
just like give me all my drugs and just
let me take them all
let me die with them death by OD yeah oh
man oh yeah the first execution
conducted by lethal Jackson in Vietnam
was over a guy who murdered a gas
station employee 2013. interesting first
lethal ingestion was 2013. prior to that
it was all firing squad that's why I'm
sure it doesn't but like what we're uh
these two wins professions before they
were admitted to a psychiatric work
because if they're Club promoters I'm
like that's [ __ ] I'm sure they were
they were definitely probably drug
dealers because they they were able to
move such high amounts and maybe they
weren't even crazy they probably you
know like some criminals to like not go
to jail they'll create some sort of like
hoax or fraud to get into the cycle
because it's easier so they could have
finessed the whole better movie yeah
they could have finessed the whole thing
I'm in on this story man the story is
phenomenal it's sick as hell but like I
mean it's a very uh triumphant ending in
a way because I want to see what their
last thoughts and and quotes were I
wonder what the first thought like how
did they have like I'm in there yeah
it's just like the lights just turned on
in his head like okay let's make money
I'm doing it this way the date that guy
dies I want to see like the [ __ ] head
guy he's like this and then that guy
dies and he just has a team
everyone's all sad yeah they're like
geez man that was like the best time of
their life give him a chance to write
the film you're writing it for them dude
oh he turns around he just walks away
like he's all normal you were normal the
whole time oh that's the twist watch the
[ __ ] off his eyes
[Laughter]
staying crazy you don't be [ __ ] up if
these guys weren't even like there's
nothing wrong like there's nothing
happened there's like they don't have
any disabilities it's just that like you
know how like some places they don't
they're not up to par with psychology
and [ __ ] yet so they just be like man
you acting weird dude I think you're
crazy and then they send them to the
hospital and it was just like maybe
maybe he was just hyperactive or maybe
it was just some [ __ ] like they're like
oh you're doing drugs you have to go to
the psychiatric hospital you know what I
mean like yeah so you're saying maybe
there's nothing wrong with them but they
went to a psych ward and through parties
with drugs and then had orgies in a
soundproof room for two years I actually
believe he wasn't crazy because you
think about like he probably owed money
to some bookies or he owes money some
gangsters like you know what whatever it
takes to get me in there I'll do
whatever it takes just to get me out
because I'm sure they're like let's slap
him on the wrist and let him go like nah
he's crazy he's going in like I don't
have to work I don't have to like pay
back any debt I don't have to hide from
anybody I'm crazy in here and everyone
else thinks I'm crazy they're gonna
leave me alone give me a pass or what if
it's like America where like you don't
want to go to regular jail so you
pretend to be crazy so you could be like
going to uh institution instead which
yeah sometimes is worse too yeah but
then uh another thing this guy did he's
such an entrepreneur man he recruited he
recruited those recovering addicts to
sell to become drug dealers once they
got out dude so he was making there's
nobody was crazy he was training he was
training drug dealers inside the
confines of a psych ward that's why the
government's like looking at this [ __ ]
like death by execution for sure yeah
can't let this guy back you guys too
[ __ ] smart man it could just be a
full-on sociopath and then he's
diagnosed as that and as a threat to
society so then like he they threw him
in there he made the drug addicts drug
dealers again I think that's pretty
intense that's sensitive dude that is
some crazy promotion right there
teaching a crazy person how to run a
business like and he was successful oh
yeah back to community service over here
he probably got them sane though they
were crazy and they were able to go on
the world and become drug dealers that
means he was able to coach him train to
be normal he's the Cure he taught them
that don't get hired your own Supply
thing the first rule of being a dealer
yeah this guy's amazing man or like the
the first day he discovered the
soundproof boom he's like hello oh [ __ ]
hey come here man
hello
[Music]